hi in this video we'll talk about
competitive inhibition now what comes in
your mind when you hear the term
competitive inhibition somebody is
competing with somebody right now first
of all it's a type of reversible
reaction or reversible inhibition in
which the effect of the inhibitor can be
reversed under certain circumstances and
we would learn about that so in this
kind of situation when normally enzyme
and substrate binds to each other the
competitive inhibitor competes with the
substrate and it binds with the enzymes
active site since both substrate and
inhibitor binds to the enzymes active
site that means the substrate and the
inhibitor has some degree of structural
similarity right so let's try to
understand competitive inhibition in a
lot more details
normally the enzyme would interact with
the substrate
which would eventually lead to a enzyme
substrate complex formation which is
transient and eventually it would give
rise to a product now in case of
competitive inhibition
since our inhibitor has a very similar
structure like the substrate it would
compete for the active site of the
enzyme and it would form an enzyme and
inhibitor complex now this enzyme and
inhibitor complex prevent the enzyme to
interact with the substrate and give
rise to a product so product formation
does not take place so this is the
empirical view of the competitive
innovation but let's try to understand
how the Michaelis Menten equation looks
like under this situation so here we
have written it in a format of the
kinetics where we are assuming the
enzyme plus substrate give rise to our
enzyme substrate complex yes and then
product is form and the enzyme remains
unchanged and we have considered all the
rate constant for these steps and here
we are adding and competitive inhibitor
I and the formation of the
enzyme inhibitor complex is denoted by
this step and the rate constant for that
is K I for this particular reaction now
we can simply using the laws of
equilibrium we can understand ki is
concentration of enzyme into inhibitor
divided by enzyme inhibitor complex
concentration right and we can further a
little bit modulate it in a format like
this and why we are doing this in a
moment it would be clear now we know
while the enzyme substrate reaction is
happening that total enzyme
concentration in this particular case
would be free enzyme concentration plus
enzyme which is in a format of enzyme
substrate complex because inhibitor
cannot any bind to all of the enzymes
right some amount of substrate binding
always happens so that particular
species would be there the enzyme
substrate complex and some amount of a
majority of that would be a enzyme and
inhibitor complex so we have three
species here now we would try to rewrite
it the concentration of enzyme and
inhibitor from the formula that we
previously derived and then take es as
common which would lead us to this kind
of algebraic expression now from that if
we now understand what is the
concentration of es means we derive and
we come to this particular situation
then we know that enzyme velocity is
kind of k2 into es so multiplying both
sides by k2 would leads us to the
following expression and here we can for
simplicity we can define this one by
inhibitor / ki has an alpha at armed as
alpha and ultimately we can write V 0
equal to v-max into substrate
concentration divided by alpha came now
this expression we have previously
denoted as alpha plus substrate
concentration and we also know that k2 e
t means v-max whereas v-0 is equal to k2
es
from that we come to this situation and
this is how the Michaelis Menten
equation look like under a situation of
competitive inhibitor now let's try to
look at how does the Michaelis Menten
curve look under this competitive
inhibitor situation so this is normally
the Michaelis Menten curve where with
the increase of substrate concentration
the enzyme velocity or the rate of
reaction increase but after a certain
certain time it reached plateau with
very high level of substrate now this is
how the curve look like when it is with
the competitive inhibitor now clearly we
can see there is not much change in the
v-max where there is a dramatic shift of
came towards the right side that means
the game is higher than the normal game
definitely it is understandable because
now the affinity towards the substrate
would be decreased increasing came means
decrease in affinity right now in order
to better understand the kinetic data we
can represent the same thing in a double
reciprocal plot plot which is
lineweaver-burk plot in the
lineweaver-burk plot what we would
understand is a normal the Michaelis
Menten equation looks like somewhere
this here we have plotted everything in
a scale of 1 by V by 1 by s and the
slope is game by V Max and the intercept
is 1 by V Max right intercept here is 1
by V Max now and it would and now if we
do a competitive inhibition the line
looks like some word like this you can
clearly understand the line is more
steeper that means there is alteration
in the slope indeed the slope is alpha
km by V Max for any values of alpha any
positive values of alpha you can always
understand the slope is steeper right
that means game has changed now the
question
is how we can reverse this kind of
inhibition and here in this particular
graph you can see with the increase in
alpha value that line would get steeper
and steeper and the degree of inhibition
would be stronger and stronger because
km would increase and the affinity for
the substrate towards enzyme would
decrease so in order to reverse this
what we can do but before that we should
learn about an example normally
succinate is acted upon by succinate
dehydrogenase which lead it lead to the
convert conversation to fumarate now
malonate which has a similar structure
like succinate can competitively inhibit
succinate dehydrogenase and as a result
no product is formed
that's how melanin act like a
competitive inhibitor of succinate now
once we learned about the example we
should try to understand that how we can
reverse the effect of competitive
inhibition and the answer is simple we
can increase the substrate concentration
and if we increase the substrate
concentration the probability that the
substrate would encounter the enzymes
active site is far more than the
probability of interaction between
inhibitor and substrate and that's how
the effect of these competitive
inhibitor can be reversed and that's how
the we can get rid of the inhibition so
that was pretty much about the
competitive inhibition so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you